[Musique]
on ne pourrait imaginer meilleure
fiction que les événements réels qui
émaillent la vie d'henri de bourbon les
faits à eux seuls dispense le romanesque
le suspense l'intriguent et la fourberie
que l'on exige d'une histoire
henri iv fut incontestablement un des
monarques les plus dignes de s'asseoir
sur le trône de france mais les
péripéties qui menèrent à son événement
100 points elle même un roman on voit
des rivalités entre eux des branches
différentes des familles royales
l'histoire de l'a20 archi française ce
n'est pas un fleuve tranquille
en 15 189 au moment où henri de navarre
premier bourbon a régné sur la france
accède au trône paris est en plein chaos
au bout de deux cent soixante ans de
règne
la maison de valois connaître une fin
peu glorieuse
la reine catherine de médicis grande
matriarche ne pouvait s'empêcher de voir
dans son neveu une menace
c'est pour cette raison et parce qu'il
avait été élevé dans la foi protestante
qu'il fût surveiller manipuler et même
emprisonné par la famille royale qui
voulait l'empêcher de devenir un
dirigeant huguenots
[Musique]
lorsqu il put échapper à la cour et à
l'emprise de catherine henry livrent à
un combat après l'autre dans l'espoir
d'assurer la sécurité de la france et de
voir fleurir la tolérance religieuse
finalement ses cousins étant tous mort
sans descendance il fut proclamé roi de
france et se fraya un chemin à travers
les provinces pour venir à paris réclamé
son trône
m
[Musique]
mais non
henri roi de navarre n'est pas destiné à
l'origine à continuer en 453 devenir
henri iv roi de france et de navarre
c'est parce qu'il est descendant de la
lointaine branche bourbon qui est un des
rameaux de la famille un cap et sienne
en fait par son père antoine de bourbon
le futur henri iv descend du trône de
saint louis
henri de bourbon vient au monde au
milieu du xvième siècle en 15/100 53
c'est un enfant de la renaissance
à sa naissance ce courant de changement
culturel politique et religieux touche à
sa fin
la renaissance époque de découverte et
de changements ces temps de 13 175 à 15
cette période correspond quasiment au
règne des valois sur la france
mais ce n'est pas avant le 16e siècle
que françois premier combattant en
italie découvre ces nouvelles manière
passionnante de regarder le monde il
rapportera avec lui en france la
renaissance italienne
à la fin des années 15 cents les grands
princes d'europe ont réalisé l'unité à
l'intérieur de leur propre pays et
maintenant les princes ambitieux et
aventurier cherche à élargir leur
pouvoir et leur richesse au delà des
frontières
pour cela ils peuvent soit s'emparer des
terres de leurs voisins soit partir à la
découverte de nouveaux territoires
l'acquisition de nouvelles colonies
renforce considérablement la position de
l'espagne et de son roi charles quint
la transe quand elle commence à se
sentir vulnérable
il faudra bien du temps à françois 1er
et à son fils henry 2 pour restaurer la
position de la france face à charles
quint et son fils philippe ii d'espagne
en 15 117 durant le règne de françois
1er un moine allemand du nom de martin
luther remettent en question les
enseignements de l'église catholique
faisant ainsi écho à des dissensions
plus ancien
le terreau protestent contre la cupidité
et la corruption et le manque de
spiritualité de l'église
il exprime son effroi devant la fortune
de rome et le manque de foi qui y règne
les papes sont devenus des princes
vivent dans le luxe qui n'hésitent pas à
entrer en guerre et font bien peu pour
soulager les souffrances des pauvres
lutter rassemble ces protestations dans
un document appelé les 95 thèses et le
placardent à la porte de l'église de
wittenberg
cet acte marque le début du mouvement
religieux connu sous le nom de réforme
lutter prêche la réforme autrement dit
la transformation de la religion
catholique
d'autres réformateurs comme jean calvin
français établis à genève vont encore
plus loin dans leur critique des
pratiques ecclésiastiques les
calvinistes estime que les ors et les
cérémonies de l'église romaine et le
besoin d'un prêtre comme intercesseur
écarte le peuple de l'expérience de dieu
les seniors qui ont embrassé le
calvinisme protestante ils sont sous
l'influencé de prédicateurs
calviniste fameux théodore de bèze
notamment qui est un orateur remarquable
qui leur explique qu'il faut abandonner
le catholicisme parce que cette les
donatrices qu'est ce que ça veut dire
d'aller prier des ça comme ça les
statuts devant chaque église c'est pas
ça le christianisme le christ aime c'est
un message évangélique
il faut le lire directement il faut le
lire dans le texte toutes ces critiques
conduisent finalement à une rupture avec
l'église catholique et à la constitution
d'église dédié à la religion réformée
celle ci compte de plus en plus
d'adeptes que l'on commence à connaître
sous le nom de protestants une grande
partie de l'allemagne des états
scandinaves et de la grande-bretagne
adopte les idées de la réforme ces
nouvelles églises nationales ne
reconnaissent plus l'autorité morale et
spirituelle du pape ces seigneurs ça
leur plaît beaucoup ça leur plaît parce
que c'est une théologie simple et
logique mais surtout parce que ça enlève
du pou va à l'église donc ça leur donne
un peu plus de pouvoir et ça leur permet
dans les endroits gagné par le
protestantisme me supprime les impôts
que les paysans que tout le tiers et a
payé à
payer à l'église et c'est autant
d'argent pour eux en plus à cause de la
proximité de genève où s'est réfugiée
calvin la réforme se répand en france
l'âpre querelle qui oppose catholiques
et protestants français dit huguenots au
cours dé règne de françois 1er et de son
fils henri ii
va donner naissance aux guerres de
religion de véritables guerres civiles
qui éclate en 15 162 alors qu henri de
navarre le futur henri iv n'a que neuf
ans elles vont durer presque 50 en ville
le peuple doit se convertir rapidement à
la nouvelle religion on badigeonne
toutes les églises en rond dans l'est
l'on casse les les statuts de sa celles
qui sont en bois on les brûle et puis on
devient protestants et ça c'est
évidemment cette install party qui gagne
du terrain et le parti catholique au
pouvoir de plus en plus acculé cherche
des accords cherche quand il faut faire
la guerre on fait la guerre et c'est une
période épouvantable parce que pendant
ce temps là on saccage le pays
[Musique]
le mariage des parents d'henri iv eu
lieu à l'automne 15 148
antoine de bourbon descendant direct du
sixième fils de saint louis robert de
bourbon et le premier prince de sang
hériter du trône après levallois
françois 1er qui descend lui aussi de
saint-louis son épouse jeanne d'albret
et la nièce du roi et la fille d'henri
d'albret roi de navarre
ce mariage lui apporte les avantages de
soutenir ses aspirations politiques
pourtant les deux époux se marie par
amour
la mère de jeanne d'albret la mystique
et très cultivé marguerite de navarre
était adorée par son frère françois 1er
celui ci savait que sa soeur était doué
d'un esprit politique puissant et
représenter un atout inestimable pour le
trône
marguerite mettait tout son esprit son
talent et son énergie au service de son
frère bien aimé le roi
et quand elle accoucha de son premier
enfant jeanne elle bénéficia aussi de la
faveur du roi
elle grandit fille de roi et de deux
courts
françois 1er avait pour projet de garder
jeanne auprès de lui et de s'en servir
là où elle serait le plus utile au
royaume
ses premières années se passèrent loin
du château paternelle de pau dans les
châteaux de l'ombre et et blois
c'était une forte tête impulsive qui
rejeta plusieurs soupirs en avant de
s'éprendre d'une très belle antoine de
bourbon
henry 2 succède à françois 1er et son
épouse catherine de médicis de 20 rennes
et c'est henri 2 qui fut présent au
mariage de jeanne en 15/100 48
au cours des années 15,150 la france
était toujours engagé dans les guerres
interminables avec le saint-empire
jeanne n'aime pas être loin d'antoine
durant les premières années de son
mariage elle le rejoint très souvent
dans ces campements en picardie
bien qu'elle soit enceinte elle reste
auprès de son mari parcourant la
campagne dans l'espoir de le rencontrer
antoine qui ne veut pas que son enfant
naisse sur un champ de bataille parvient
à la rejoindre en septembre pour un long
séjour dans le comté du béarn dans le
petit royaume de navarre
il arrive au château de pau au début du
mois de décembre
et 10 jours plus tard le 13 décembre 15
153 jeanne enfante d'un garçon robuste
la légende veut qu une fois le bébé né
le grand père d'henri l'enveloppa dans
les plis de sa cape et ont dit à sa
fille un coffret d'or contenant son
testament en lui disant ceci est pour
vous mais celui ci est pour moi
ayant longtemps rêvé de regagner une
partie de son royaume qui avait été
conquis et usurpé à ses parents par le
habsbourg ferdinand d'aragon en 15/100
12 le grand-père était certain que le
nouveau-né resterait en grandissant le
royaume de navarre dans sa gloire passée
mais le vieux roi ne vécut pas assez
longtemps pour voir son rêve s'accomplir
il mourut le 24 mai 15 155
sa fille jeanne d'albret reine de
navarre la reine jeanne comme l'appelait
le peuple continue à de suivre partout
son mari
il faut pas imaginer henri iv comme un
petit paysan qui devient roi de france
même si on l'a souvent dépeint ainsi
c'est vrai il a eu une éducation de
petits paysans c'est son grand-père
henri d'albret le roi de navarre qui
avait voulu qu'il en soit ainsi il
l'avait confié à une famille noble des
environs pour les miossaises et il leur
avait dit il faut qu'il ait les jeux
d'un enfant de son âge mais qui parle le
béarn et la langue des petits paysans
simplement à certaines heures ou vers de
précepteur qui venait l'instruire le
prof de latin lui apprendre le français
lui apprendre à écrire et il était très
intelligent très doué
[Musique]
et
sur le terrain de la longue querelle
avec les habsbourgs gh le roi henry 2
continue simplement là où son père
s'était arrêté il décide de se tourner
vers les ennemis de charles quint les
princes allemands protestants il leur
promet son aide à condition qu'il le
laisse reprendre trois forteresses
stratégique en lorraine le long de la
frontière avec l'allemagne toul metz et
verdun
les princes accepte cette alliance est
trop puissante pour l'espagne et charles
quint accepte de faire la paix
ensuite henri décide de suivre les
traces de son père et d'envahir l'italie
il a l'intention d'assurer contre les
apps bourgue la domination française sur
les affaires européennes
il lance la campagne d'italie en 15 150
parfois appelée duel valois habsburg
[Musique]
charles 5 abdique en faveur de son fils
en 15/100 56 mais en 15 100 59 les deux
parties sont épuisés et à court d'argent
henri ii et philippe deux signent un
traité de paix à cateau cambrésis en
avril de la même année henri renonce à
l'italie mais reçoit calais des anglais
la paix est revenue et cette longue
série de conflits entre la france et
l'espagne prend momentanément fin
la paix est de courte durée
henri ii est un colosse bel homme rompu
à tous les exercices physiques il tient
beaucoup de françois 1er son père et
henry 2 ème beaucoup l'un des camps
sports des gens de sa catégorie j'allais
dire c'est à dire des rois des princes
de la grande noblesse qu'elle est
tournoi se substitue delà de la guerre
il affronte un capitaine ne s'égare d'
qui s'appelle mungo mairie
la lance de bongo père y seront se casse
et un petit bout de l'as lens vient dans
la visière du casque se loger dans
l'oeil dans les bains
[Musique]
la reine mère se trouve dans une
situation extrêmement vulnérables les
tensions religieuses sont en train de se
transformer en guerre civile qui vont
ranger le pays de l'intérieur
son mari lui laisse cinq jeunes enfants
un royaume divisé et trois autres
familles rivales qui prétendant au trône
bien qu'elle se sente en sécurité avec
quatre fils héritier de la couronne ils
sont encore très jeune et facilement
manipulable
il lui faut manoeuvrer et défendre son
rôle de premier conseiller face aux
autres maisons qui peuvent vouloir
accéder au pouvoir
les rivaux de ses fils sont leurs
cousins les princes de sang bourbon
antoine le père du jeune henry et ses
frères charle cardinal de bourbon et
louis de bourbon prince de condé
il y a aussi deux autres familles
prétendantes la maison des montmorency
et celle des guise
anne de montmorency et connétable et
grand maître de france il est catholique
mais à trois neveux une eau dont le
talentueux amiral gaspard de coligny
les montmorency occupe une position
confortable avec un pied dans chaque
camp
l'église sont des catholiques fanatiques
bien qu'il ne soit pas de lignées
royales ils ont donné une reine à
l'ecosse mary 2 ghz et une reine de
france leur nièce marie stuart et maria
françois 2 le fils aîné de catherine
[Musique]
tandis qu'henri de gym mourant dans le
vieux palais des tournelles et qu'il est
clair qu'il ne se remettra pas de ces
blessures catherine rassemble ses
enfants et fils au louvre suivie de la
famille de guise son fils aîné françois
qui à tout juste 16 ans est aussitôt
proclamé roi sous le nom de françois 2
et couronnée en la cathédrale de reims
le 10 juillet
la conjuration d'amboise se déroule en
mars qu'un 160 on appelle conjuration en
réalité un mouvement mené par un certain
nombre de seniors protestant de seniors
huguenots qui considère que le jeune roi
de france le petit françois ii et sa
famille ne peuvent pas renier parce
qu'ils sont aux mains de princes
catholique tyrannique né prince de la
maison de lorraine l'église c'est
conjurer protestants en réalité vont se
faire prendre et la mort soudaine d'un
autre roi interrompt le procès qui
devait suivre et permet à condé et
navarre d'être relâchés
françois est mort terrassé par une otite
qui a dégénéré en abcès au cerveau
le prince henri de navarre alors âgé de
6 ans a commencé à être instruits dans
la foi protestante quand son cousin
charles deuxième fils de catherine de
médicis monte sur le trône
charles à 9 ans n'a que quelques années
de plus qu henry et sa mère voit enfin
la possibilité d'agrandir son pouvoir et
de gouverner en tant que régente jusqu'à
ce que charles atteigne la majorité
catherine de médicis depuis l'avènement
de charles neuf jours sujet de bascule
entre l'église et le parti protestant en
15 161 antoine de bourbon effet
lieutenant général du royaume
aveuglés par cette promotion et les
promesses d'une future navarre resterait
il change de camp sa vanité le rend
aveugle aux manipulations de catherine
de médicis et de la famille de guise
après avoir embrassé la réforme deux ans
plus tôt il retourne à la religion de la
reine-mère il se bat pour convaincre sa
femme de renoncer elle aussi au
protestantisme et dès lors leur union ne
sera plus jamais la même
il est bientôt clair que jeanne d'albret
préférerait mourir plutôt que d'assurer
sa foi
elle reçoit donc l'ordre de quitter la
cour en 15 162 mais son fils henry doit
y rester
antoine meurt à la fin de l'année des
suites de blessures reçues en combattant
le parti catholique au cours de la
première guerre de religion
jeanne d'albret revient à la cour et le
prince est de nouveau élevée dans la
religion calviniste
henry à 9 ans en quinze cent soixante
deux camps se déclenchent les guerres de
religion et que son père meurt
l'âpre querelle entre les deux factions
qui grondait depuis de nombreuses années
entre a finalement en éruption tel un
volcan
les engagements majeurs de la première
guerre se déroule ra rouen dreux et
orléans
le siège de rouen va durer de mai à
octobre 15 162 la bataille de dreux en
décembre 15 162 voix la capture de condé
par le duc de guise et le connétable de
montmorency gouverneur général est fait
prisonnier par les bobos
mais les protestants tienne orléans
morency et condé sont maintenant captifs
navarre est mort françois de guise et
que s'il parvient à prendre orléans il
deviendra l'homme le plus puissant de
france
le formidable chef de la maison de
lorraine serait sans doute devenu maître
du royaume et seul gardien de l'enfant
royal s'il avait été assassiné par un
jeune seigneur du nom de jean de poltrot
de méré
ce meurtre provoque une insurrection
populaire
orléans résiste au siège auquel la
soumettent les catholiques catherine et
force est de conclure une trêve et de
signer lesdits d'amboise en 15/100 63
pendant ce temps à la cour henri étudié
au collège de navarre
ses condisciples sont henry le nouveau
duc de guise et son royal cousin le
prince henri futur henri iii
les trois henry vont grandir ensemble et
jouer des rôles de premier plan dans le
drame qui décidera du destin de la
france
ce qui ajoute aux craintes de catherine
de médicis c'est qu'elle ne parvient pas
à séduire jeanne d'albret avec les
hordes sa somptueuse cour renaissance
jeanne n'est nullement impressionnés par
les vices et les manières raffinées de
cette société
finalement en 15/100 67 las de se sentir
méprisés en tant que protestante elle
trouve le moyen de fuir avec son fils et
retourne à pau dans le palais
renaissance où il est né
depuis son royaume vallonnées du béarn
entouré par deux puissances catholique
elle prêtait au mouvement grandissant
aides conseils argent et armes
la seconde guerre a lieu à l'automne de
la même année
les huguenots entraîne la france dans un
conflit de six mois qui se termine par
la paix de longjumeau
le synchronisme entre le retour de jane
en navarre et cette deuxième guerre
civile l'a fait passer aux yeux des
catholiques comme une conspiratrice
l'année suivante en 15 168 la couronne
révoque formellement les 10 de janvier
15 162 qui offrait quelques libertés
religieuses au rugueux nos dès lors
pratiquer le protestantisme est
considérée comme un acte de sédition
pendant ce temps à pau henri complète
son éducation et commence sa formation
de futur roi de navarre
la reine jeanne le fait lieutenant
général du royaume de navarre on lui
enseigne à manier l'épée avec talent
ainsi que la hache la hallebarde et les
ce ponton
jeanne le présente à l'armée huguenote
il participe ensuite au campagne sous le
commandement du seul chef protestant
encore en liberté l'amiral de coligny
lors de la bataille de jarnac en mars 15
969 et de moncontour en octobre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
catherine de médicis adepte des
machinations propose un mariage
stratégique entre sa fille la princesse
marguerite et le prince henri henri de
l'est a promis la main de sa fille et
catherine de médicis tour fine politique
des biens on va exaucer la province de
mon mari on va lui donner marguerite de
valois comme épouse
en choisissant son neveu elle a pour but
de mettre fin aux guerres civiles qui
met en péril la stabilité de la
monarchie cette alliance est une
tentative pour redonner du pouvoir aux
bâlois et bénéficier d'une image de
pacificatrice
jeanne d'albret accepte à contrecoeur le
mariage de son fils avec une princesse
catholique
ça lui plaît pas du tout ce mariage puis
c'est très compliqué ce cette espèce de
danvic à catherine de médicis de faire
un mariage avec un protestant le pape
n'est pas d'accord il ne donne pas son
autorisation à ce mariage alors on ment
un peu au cardinal archevêque ou lui dis
bah l'autorisation du pape est parti de
rome et mais elle n'est pas encore
arrivée et catherine mais ici s'y tient
elle dit c'est on va on va ligoté les
protestants part salariale
avant de voir son fils marié la reine
jeanne meurt d'une très longue maladie
contractée à son arrivée à la cour
[Musique]
après la mort de sa mère henry devient
roi de navarre et le projet de mariage
royal suit son cours
les tensions sont très fortes cet été là
la france est profondément divisée par
les guerres de religion qui dévastent
l'europe catholiques et protestants se
bat et s'entretuent depuis des années
ce geste de de pacification avec les
protestants avaient fait venir des
huguenots en grand nombre à paris et
notamment tous les proches
d'henri de navarre
tout d'un coup il ya une réaction forte
des catholiques qu'ils disent mais alors
on veut peut-être faire la paix avec les
binômes qu'est ce qu'ils viennent faire
à paris mais attendez les épouses de les
épouser la soeur du roi
ils vont faire la loi
le 18 août au beau milieu de ces
hostilités le roi henri de navarre
épouse marguerite de valois la dernière
fille en vie de henry de
la ville bruit de mécontentement et
bourdonne d'incitation au meurtre
la vague de chaleur étouffante qui est
tombée sur paris ajoute encore à
l'effervescence d'une ville déjà au bord
de la rébellion
six jours plus tard l'enfer se déchaîne
de nombreux historiens pensent que le
massacre de la saint barthélemy est
inspiré par la ferveur religieuse
mais la véritable cause en est politique
catherine de médicis toujours très fait
une politique veut éliminer un autre
protestants qui est dans la place qui
est quasiment premier ministre qui est
devenu très important qui est l'amiral
de coligny et ce qui est sans doute
programmée entre
charles neuf et catherine de médicis
c'est une conspiration qui tente à
éliminer collini et quelques chef
protestant le 22 août sans que charles
soit au courant qu'au ligne est victime
d'une tentative d'assassinât ratée
catherine de médicis et le duc de guise
ne sachant comment dissimuler cet impair
décide de faire massacrer tous les
protestants de paris
comme une aiguille dans une botte de
foin le meurtre de coligny sera alors
noyé parmi les autres
mais comment convaincre charles de
donner cet ordre
catherine imagine de le manipuler si
bien qu'ils pensent que les protestants
sont en train de comploter pour se
révolter contre lui
dans la nuit du 24 août la reine ne perd
pas de temps elle utilise toutes les
ressources de sa perversité pour
retourner charles contre collini elle
lui révèle d'abord la vérité que la
tentative de meurtre contre colis me
n'est pas simplement une initiative de
guise mais kelly était mêlé ainsi
qu'henri frère du roi
elle ajoute que l'on dit que collini
n'est pas un véritable ami qui ne fait
qu'utiliser charles pour entrer en
guerre contre l'espagne est qu à
l'instant même il est en train de
planifier un soulèvement contre la
famille royale
la peur et la colère exit la folie de
charles
alors que se passe-t-il le 24 août et
bien c'est que tout dérape il se produit
une espèce folie collective
difficile de dire si la conspiration
consistait à tuer autant de protestants
je ne le crois pas je pense que il
s'agissait d'éliminer quelques chefs
simplement mais que tout a dérapé
navarre et son cousin le prince de condé
sont convoqués à l'aube dans les
chambres du voit les gens de leurs
suites sont priés de rester dans
l'antichambre
charles les informe du massacre à venir
et leur dit qu'ils seront épargnés
syllabes sur leur foi
pendant ce temps les gentilhommes de
leurs suites sont exécutés dans les
couloirs du palais navarre et condé sont
forcés d'écouter les hurlements de leurs
compagnons qui n'ayant aucune issue sont
assassinés sur place
les gardes suisses d'henri sont
facilement maîtrisé et l'amiral et
poignardé dans le dos et précipité par
la fenêtre en bas le duc de guise à
temps pour l'achever une fois ce forfait
accompli il donne le signal du massacre
les cloches du beffroi de saint germain
l'auxerrois sonne le début des atrocités
les entrées de paris sont fermés et les
catholiques par assassiner tous les
protestants dans les demeures ont été au
préalable désigner leurs corps sont tout
simplement jetés à la seine qui restera
rouge de leurs sons pendant plusieurs
jours
dans la seine ont jeté des corps et puis
après ouais qui se noyait pas assez vite
on les retire et avec une pique aux in
lançons les poignarder on les remettait
dos est une espèce de folie criminel
sanguinaire
[Musique]
henry a échappé de peu à la mort
malgré l'humiliation il saisi la chance
qui lui est offerte d'avoir la vie sauve
en reniant sa foi
un mois plus tard condé et lui sont au
coeur d'une cérémonie très élaborés ou
il abjure publiquement la fois réformer
le jeune henri de navarre se retrouve
emprisonné en tout cas en liberté
surveillée à la cour de france depuis la
saint barthélemy depuis août 15 172 il
va rester à la cour dans une situation
très compliquée de 15 172 jusqu'au début
de 15,76 le trône polonais est offert en
15/100 73 au troisième fils de catherine
de médicis henri duc d'anjou
charles neuf succombe à une mort précoce
il meurt en mai quelques mois après
l'avènement de son frère dans ce royaume
lointain
du fait de la mort de son frère henri
d'anjou est rappelé de pologne pour
monter sur le trône sous le nom d'henri
iii
malgré les lettres de sa mère qui le
pressent de rentrer en france car elle
veut voir au plus vite son fils préféré
couronné roi henry prend trois mois
entier pour revenir dans son pays
préférant passer l'été en italie berceau
de la renaissance
le 13 février 15 175 henri iii est
couronné roi en la cathédrale de reims
une autre tentative d'évasion mal
préparée pendant les funérailles du roi
charles conduit navarra se résigner à
son sort il se montre agréable et docile
à la cour du nouveau roi henri iii
voyant là sa meilleure chance de
s'échapper vivant
l'avare joue son rôle à merveille
entouré d'une cour d'amis mais en
réalité la vie à la cour est pleine de
pièges dangereux
marguerite de navarre batifole avec ses
nombreux admirateurs
et de son côté henry prend une maîtresse
charlotte de sauver première d'une
longue série qui vaudra au bouillant
béarnais le surnom de vert galant
au bout de trois ans et demi de semis
captivité dans une cour désoeuvrés et
hostile navarre et là
sous les encouragements de son ami et
partisan agrippa d'aubigné
il passe à l'action en 15 100 76
les dix années suivantes après qu'henry
a fui le louvre marque une pause
enchantée dans le cours de sa vie pleine
de rebondissements
ayant perdu le contrôle de son royal
cousin le roi signe quelques mois plus
tard lady de beaulieu par lequel est
accordée aux gueux nos un certain nombre
de concessions
ces années de paix toute relative
permettent à navarre d'établir sa propre
cour et de perfectionner ses talents de
jeunes galant
pendant ce temps se forment un nouveau
parti politique
les ultra-catholiques sont fermement
opposés aux tentatives récentes du roi
pour réconcilier les deux factions
opposées
aussi faut-il un mouvement appelé la
ligue catholique ou sainte ligue
henri duc de guise en est le chef
quelques années plus tard henri de
navarre prend pour maîtresse une jeune
femme de sa cour mademoiselle de
montmorency faut se dit la belle fausse
euse
elle finit par tomber enceinte et c'est
marguerite qui est appelée pour aider à
la naissance de l'enfant
marguerite usent de cette liaison comme
prétexte pour quitter la cour en vérité
elle est lasse de l'austérité huguenote
en mars 15 182 après avoir passé quatre
années aux côtés de son époux à nérac et
pau elle s'en retourne à la cour de son
frère
henri déconcerté par ce changement de
situation continue à profiter en parfait
galles en défaveur de jeunes femmes de
gascogne et de guyenne
l'année suivante il tombe profondément
amoureux de la comtesse de grammont une
amie de sa soeur henri est totalement
sous le charme de corisande comme il
l'appelle
le 10 juin 15 184 le quatrième est plus
jeune fils de catherine hercules plus
connu sous le nom de françois de valois
moeurs
cette disparition fée de son cousin le
roi de navarre un héritier présomptif
la mort du frère du roi marque le début
de la guerre des trois henry ces trois
hommes qui enfant avait fréquenté
ensemble les bancs du collège de navarre
se retrouve à présent en compétition
pour la couronne
en 15 187 donc c'est ce qu'on peut
appeler la guerre des trois henry il ya
le roi de france henri iii il ya le
parti du roi de la ligue finalement
henri de guise et le parti des
protestants celui d'henri de navarre
depuis quand rick navarre s'enfuit de la
cour de france jusqu'à son avènement en
15189 il ya un long chemin un long
chemin d'affirmation politique un long
chemin d'affirmation et de conquête
militaire de sa position
durant l'été 15 187 une élite de l'armée
royale se dirige vers le sud sur les
terres contrôlées par les huguenots et
leur mènent une guerre d'usure attaquant
par une centaine de petites escarmouches
toujours au front le risque et les
épreuves de la guerre réussissent à
henri de navarre il reste à cheval
pendant des mois à la fin de l'été il
est prête à attaquer la ligne sur son
propre terrain car finalement la reine
elizabeth d'angleterre lui a fourni
secrètement des fonds pour adjoindre à
ses troupes des mercenaires allemands au
début de la bataille de coutras henry
est un peu pris au dépourvu par la
proximité de l'armée royale malgré tout
il exalte ses hommes par son optimisme
face à l'ennemi ils hurlent ils sont à
nous gloire à dieu au service du roi
notre souverain récoltons les honneurs
et sauve en l'état
les combats sont rudes mais à mi journée
ils sont victorieux la bataille de
coutras et la première victoire
importante dans riant cinq ans et sa
première grande victoire militaire comme
général en chef il a gagné par son seul
courage et son sens tactique
c'est un succès sans pareil dans
l'histoire des guerres de religion
il met fin aux derniers espoirs de la
ligue pour éradiquer les huguenots
[Musique]
en mars 15 188 navarre doit d'affronter
un coup terrible
il écrit ta corisande une des plus
grandes tragédies que j'ai jamais
redouté vient de se produire c'est la
mort subite du prince
on pense que le prince de condé
bouillant et fier huguenots a été
empoisonné sa mort est un triomphe pour
la ligue leur adversaire rugueux n'en
ont perdu un chef talentueux est ce le
coup fatal pour navarre ses troupes
épuisés ne sont pas de taille face à
celle d'henry de guise et de la ligue
[Musique]
pour les astrologues et autres de 20 de
l'époque 15 188 est une année de funeste
présage
le royaume est appelé à vivre une
catastrophe
l'épisode majeur du conflit religieux
prend place cette année là
10 a toujours communiqué secrètement
avec philippe 2 il reçoit des fonds afin
de lutter pour l'abolition de la
religion réformée et empêcher le prince
protestant d'accéder au trône ce soutien
a été une réussite la ligue est le parti
le plus puissant du royaume à paris ces
démagogues un timide le parlement sape
l'autorité du roi en toute occasion et
convaincre la populace qu'ils sont les
protecteurs de la foule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en mai 15 188 henri de guise à
l'admiration du peuple le soutien
politique de l'église romaine et l'appui
militaire et financier de l'espagne
même le roi ne peut ignorer qu'un climat
de révolution enfle dans les rues de la
capitale
les relations entre henri iii roi de
france et le grand chef de la ligue
catholique du duc de guise sont très
tendues tellement tendue que le roi de
france a interdit au duc de guise de
revenir à la cour en 15 100 88 c'est
ambitieux pense que le temps est venu
pour lui d'intervenir de dépouiller le
roi de son pouvoir et de prendre les
rênes du pays
dépassant les ordres du roi le duc de
guise revient à paris au printemps de 15
188 et il est accueilli dans la capitale
comme un nouveau christ entrant à
jérusalem c'est un triomphateur les gens
touchent son manteau quand ils passent
dans les rues les femmes s'agenouille
pour le roi c'est un scandale
inexcusable comment peut-il défier aussi
franchement l'autorité du roi plus
catholique que tout autre assis sur le
trône par la volonté de dieu et où un de
l'huile sainte divine
beaucoup d'ultra catholiques voient dans
cet acte audacieux une tentative de
sauvegarder l'église romaine ce qui le
justifie à leurs yeux
on ne sait pas ce qu'ils se sont dit
mais après avoir discuté catherine et 10
se dirige vers le louvre fendant la
foule qui s'est rassemblé là
la ville attend avec impatience que le
pouvoir soit transféré aux mains de
l'héroïque 10
après deux entrevues avec celui ci les
craintes denrées augmente il est clair
qu'il est en train de perdre paris mais
attaquer la ligue ne ferait que soulever
son peuple contre lui
ses conseillers lui suggère une tactique
pour vaincre la ligue sans effusion de
sang
le roi fait rentrer des troupes des
soldats de ces gardes français et des
troupes suisses qui vont s'installer
dans les carrefours les places le
cimetière des innocents pour essayer de
contrôler la capitale
le plan est ingénieux et exécuter
brillamment mais la ligue n'a pas dit
son dernier mot les bourgeois parisiens
qui sont membres de la milice sortent
leurs armes ça semble dans les rues et
vont fermer les rues vont faire débat
ricane c'est la première fois qu'on va
employer véritablement ce mot c'est à
dire qu'ils vont prendre des marines des
tonneaux qui ne vont les remplir de
terre ou de pavés pour faire des pour
fermer les rues ils vont tendre les
chaînes et les troupes suisses et
françaises vont se trouver emprisonné
finalement ils ne vont plus pouvoir
manoeuvrer elles vont finir par déposer
les armes et c'est une grande
humiliation pour le roi de france de se
voir déborder par des bourgeois
parisiens qui sont encouragés en sous
main par le duc de guise et les hommes
de la ligue catholique
[Musique]
et
à l'issue de la journée des barricades
henri iii est débordé il s'enferme dans
le château du louvre et devant le danger
il va s'enfuir le lendemain il va se
réfugier à chartres le duc de guise
apparaît comme l'homme fort au printemps
de 588 et il va imposer un orri 3 de
déclarer publiquement une nouvelle fois
que la couronne de france ne peut
revenir qu'à un prince catholique en
gris 3 doit remettre la moitié des
grandes forteresses et tous les postes
de commandement du royaume à la ligue
enfin guy lui même doit être fait
lieutenant général du royaume
le roi de france accepte mais il est au
fond de lui extrêmement humiliés par les
conditions que lui impose le duc de
guise même si naturellement henri iii
est un droit parfaitement catholique qui
n'a aucune sympathie pour le monde
protestant mais il est attaché à la
défense de la tradition
plus on va vers l'hiver et plus les
tensions s'accumulent entre le duc de
guise et le roi
10 est alerté par des rumeurs
d'assassinats il menace le roi de
déclencher une guerre générale il décide
de convoquer des états généraux à boire
dans les garanties possibles et
imaginables
de guise tôt le matin du 23 décembre le
duc de guise et son frère louis 2
cardinal de guise se rendre à une
réunion du conseil du roi au château de
blois
leduc remarque le nombre inhabituel de
garder royaux dans la cour du château et
sur les marches venteuses du fameux
escalier renaissance construit par
françois 1er
lorsqu'il arrive à la chambre du conseil
on prévient guise que le roi désirent le
voir dans un salon privé attenant à sa
chambre à coucher
l'un l'égard de la sassine et arrêtent
le cardinal
henri en signe de triomphe pose le pied
sur le corps du duc morts et pour être
sûr qu'aucun prétendant au trône de
france ne soient libres d'agir contre
lui il fait emprisonner son fils ça
c'est la vengeance de l'humiliation et
c'est à ce moment là qui décide tout à
fait ouvertement après avoir fait
assassiner le duc de guise et son frère
le cardinal de leur est de s'allier donc
ouvertement avec henri de navarre pour
aller à siéger paraît il ne se doute pas
que le meurtre de ce héros populaire va
enflammer la population en moins de
temps qu'il ne faut pour le dire le
parlement ouvre une instruction
criminelle contre le roi et le peuple
excommunie pour le meurtre du cardinal
tous les espoirs de catherine de médicis
ont ruiné elle est trop vieille malade
et fatigué pour se battre encore moins
de deux semaines plus tard le 5 janvier
la grande matriarche merde trois rois
c'est un
henri de navarre aperçoit immédiatement
une ouverture la paix ne sera achevé que
par la restauration d'une monarchie
forte la chute du roi représente à ses
yeux la ruine du pays il lui offre donc
son soutien
cette fois henri iii n'est pas en
position de refuser l'aide de son cousin
protestants et il conclut tous deux une
alliance contre la ligue
le premier round 15189 henri iii loges à
saint cloud avec son armée et se prépare
à reprendre paris quand un jeune
dominicain fanatiques jacques clément
muni de faux papiers demande audience au
roi pour lui délivrer des documents
importants
le moindre mais taux souverains une
liasse de papiers puis lui déclare avoir
un message secret à lui transmettre
le roi fait un signe aux membres de sa
suite de s'éloigner et c'est alors que
clément se penche à son oreille tout en
lui plongeant un couteau dans l'abdomen
le régicide est immédiatement tué par
les gardes et cet assassinat ne sera
d'aucune utilité pour la cause
catholique puisque le successeur du roi
et protestants
avant de mourir henri s'écrit en tant
que mes amis je vous prie et vous
ordonne en tant que votre roi de
reconnaître après ma mort mon frère ici
présents et d'avoir pour lui la même
affection et fidélité que vous m'avez
toujours témoigné et il expire le matin
suivant
m
en l'espace de trente ans catherine de
médicis et quatre de ses fils sont morts
trois d'entre eux ont été roi mais aucun
n'a pu mettre au monde un héritier la
dynastie des valois laisser la place à
la maison des bourbons à laquelle
appartient le nouveau souverain c'est
ainsi qu'henri iv en tant que descendant
du roi saint louis et le premier roi
bourbon après la mort de tous ses beaux
frères
mais cette légitimité ne suffit pas à
lui assuré le trône il hérite d'un
royaume qui ne veut pas d'un roi
protestant et paris se refuse à lui
comme marguerite l'avait fait auparavant
cinq longues années vont s'écouler où il
va devoir faire preuve de vision
politique de courage et de patience
avant de pouvoir enfin entrer dans paris
et être couronnée henri iv de france et
de navarre quel destin extraordinaire
[Musique]
depuis ses plus jeunes années henry fut
témoin et participa au drame religieux
et dynastique qui ébranlait le royaume
se cristallisant autour de sa propre
personne en tant que chef d'une
opposition pour chasser ils affrontent à
une adversité de tous les instants sa
mère morte c'est ami et mentor assassiné
par sa propre famille il se retrouva
pour ainsi dire seul
s'il eu la vie sauve ce fut au prix de
l'humiliation d'une conversion au
catholicisme d'un mariage à une femme
qui se refusait à lui d'une captivité à
la cour de france contre sa volonté
pendant des années
son formidable instinct de survie lui
permit de ravaler sa fierté et de
feindre la frivolité et l'insensibilité
afin de faire diversion devant ses
ennemis
une fois libéré et occupèrent gagné
l'admiration des protestants rebelles il
partit à la tête de l'armée protestante
combattants courageusement sans relâche
et ans du rallye revirement écrasant
avec un optimisme inébranlable
il prouva qu'il était un brillant
stratège un chef courageux et un soldat
talentueux
une fois devenu l'héritier présomptif il
refusa les invitation renouvelée de ses
parts en valois qui auraient voulu qu'il
revienne à paris il laisse à son sens
politique le guide et veya attendant son
heure
henri iv est proclamé roi en 15189 sous
les plus mauvais auspices rival chanceux
des prétentions de guise au trône il est
haï par la sainte ligue le puissant
parti catholique est rejetée par le pape
mais la gaieté naturel d'henri son amour
pour son pays et le peuple de france
l'encouragent à poursuivre c'est à ce
moment qu henri iv connaît un dilemme
apparemment insurmontables s'il écoute
sa conscience embrassant la religion de
sa mère et de ce aux côtés desquels il
s'est battu pendant tant d'années il ne
sera jamais couronné roi de france et
syllabes jure le protestantisme et se
soumet aux conditions de la ligue afin
d'obtenir son soutien il perd ses alliés
de longue date en angleterre en
allemagne et en suisse ainsi que ses
frères protestants
le talent avec lequel il résout ce défi
lui permet de réaliser son but établir
la paix et la liberté religieuse et
faire de la france une grande puissance
sous le gouvernement des bourbons
c'est pourquoi on l'a surnommé henri
legrand
mon